Oh
well the first the first thing I
remember wanting to be was a
middleweight boxer and that was because
I used to punch my older brother and he
said you'll someday you'll be
middleweight champion that was my first
ambition after that I drifted to science
I think because my father was a chemist
and my mother had a great deal of
respect for sort of the social utility
of the mind and in that period which was
the late forties following World War two
early 50s people were very optimistic
about the impact of technology on
quality of life the life of an artist
was generally considered to be one of
suffering and so my parents certainly
didn't wish that on me and those were my
two choices it was either science for
the Arts we didn't have any why my
grandfather was a tailor so anything
involving the hands was out of question
and when had to live the life of the
mind and there were really these two
paths I chose science but toyed with
writing when I was in high school and
college ultimately settling on
mathematics which I really enormously
enjoyed and actually began to develop a
disdain for science because you know
science depended on the empirical world
as a source for the imagination words in
mathematics you didn't have to depend on
on the empirical world so to me I
thought mathematics was really the
highest enterprise of the mind but I
wasn't good enough at it and it was
taking me out of contact with humans so
I decided I had to do socially useful so
I went into medicine and that was a
disaster I really couldn't deal with the
uncertainty of medicine so I started
doing research instead and that's how I
ended up being
a biologist and molecular biologist so I
didn't finish medical school I went into
microbial research instead and came back
much later in my in my life to utilize
mathematics but in my case it was
entirely the influence of my parents
they had admiration for the life of the
mind and they didn't have admiration
really for anything else I mean I guess
there might have been some athletes that
they admired they admired people who
crossed broke down cultural barriers so
they had some admiration for people that
struck down political archetypes of
social archetypes but mainly they felt
that their kids should be active with
their minds and do things that they if
they enjoyed based on their own
imagination to their own training so I
never questioned that unfortunately I
didn't realize what they had done so
when I had children case Ben and Josh
behind us it didn't occur to me that you
actually had to imbue this I thought it
was just it would be natural for a child
to want to be either a scientist or an
artist and neither of my children had
any interest in science and I realized
that when it was too late so I miss that
with my kids I think to get um if one
has is a goal to have a society with
more scientists and engineers in it then
the culture has to respect people who do
that and the way these people are
depicted in the cultural media is not
generally positive
there were in the 30s a number of books
that were written I don't remember their
names you know in which scientists of
one type marie curie Louis Pasteur you
know we're depicted in dramas as heroes
but you don't see that at all anymore
instead you know usually assigned to
serve villains they're socially awkward
they're not kind of people you can
cuddle up to and I think that if popular
culture does not reflect the value of
science people aren't going to go into
it and America will be dependent upon
people coming in from from the outside
to fulfilled positions of engineers and
scientists